work more hours is the other thing and  maybe some do not statistically they do  men work more hours a lot of hours so  they must work in a lot of hours yeah  well I mean um you're you're more of the  exception you're not the rule a hundred  percent no I'm sure and I'm sure you you  mentioned I'm not going to say this on  live but your income you make more than  most men  um true yeah so how can you we say we're  discriminated against if you make more  than most men  um  that's a victim mentality and there's  quotas specifically for women they're  they're they seek out in engineering  firms they're begging women to come work  because there is none right